[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
e
décès
[Musique]
baisser
la belle
essai
on pourrait croire
que les gens sont heureux
la tête de rat dit
l'avion
ça c'était pour michel delpech vue
d'avion il ya dix ans pascal
joly de julien tout le monde tous les
téléspectateurs te connaissent pourtant
entendre à la radio sur rtl depuis de
nombreuses années stop ou encore stop
aux anciens matin dimanche matin et oui
tout le monde te connais pour te
regardant cette émission qui a reçu un
trophée dans les émissions le jeu il
s'agit d'or des meilleurs jeux sinon la
meilleure émission de jeu de la
télévision française les questions pour
un champion champions voilà et ce
champion d'animateurs a fait aussi des
chansons comme guy lux tout à l'heure
dans l'est des siennes mais et tu as
fait quelques succès on l'a vu pour
michel delpech pour herbert léonard
aussi avec herbert avec sylvie vartan
sheila michel delpech on a vendu des
millions de disques en dix ans et
notamment cette chanson et nathalie
maintenant on rentre chez toi
[Musique]
je chante pas je chante pas aussi bien
pierre bel
des data
on va soir encore une fois
[Musique]
je note julien les animateurs du service
public savent chanter on vient de voir
avec vincent perrot on l'a vu avec
jacques martin toi c'était plus secrets
on savait qu composé les chansons scoops
autour du piano de la chance aux
chansons on va voir la famille réunie
autour du piano maria rémusat chanteuse
la maman de julien leblanc et le grand
chef d'orchestre raymond le laisse les
yeux des trois d'ailleurs se ressemblent
alors le petit
écran c'est vous qui lui avait appris à
jouer du piano et bien sûr ses premières
leçons seulement pendant six mois un an
après je les connais je les fais donner
des leçons par un professeur qui est une
vieille dame derrière et il me jouait du
chopper à parker est ce que vous êtes
est-ce qu'il a joué un peu dans leur
qu'istres que vous avez longtemps dirigé
à n'ont donc jamais n'en était trop
petit alors maria rémusat voix superbe
il ya très longtemps que j'ai envie de
faire venir maria rémusat mais enchantés
je vais voir je vais réfléchir car ta
maman chante très bien le micro maria
par les apple dit un mot et vous n'êtes
jamais venu chanter ce que viendrait un
jour oui j'avais jamais d'accord je le
promets est ce qu est ce que tu as déjà
entendu ta mère chantait bien sûr et
comment moi j'ai passé tout mais j'ai
pas quand j'étais tout petit j'étais
tout le temps dans les loges des
théâtres de france et de navarre car
dieu sait si on en a fait des kilomètres
sur la rotation bi mes vocalises à la
minceur tout le temps et je voulais
réunir cette famille d'artistes autour
de ce piano pour le choisir alors alors
ça bien entendu le grand succès de
julien lepers écoutez bien pour le
plaisir
bernard
prendre de temps
de temps en temps
leur
un
enfant
et ces blues
[Musique]
s'offrir ce qui
apa
oui un peu de rêve
d'autres
à
[Musique]
c
je
usa julian assange le nuage est juste de
dire que ça a été chanté par air berlin
les textes sont écrits par flynn buggy
13 arrêts de textes réelles d'une grande
famille auteur compositeur activement
cher raymond aller à côté du fiston la
fête voir un peu comment vont jouer du
piano du jazz improvisé pas prévu reste
à côté de papa julien
vraiment lepers à côté du fils sous les
yeux de maman allez-y les musiciens en
improvise
[Musique]
dad
les
e
[Musique]
je
et c'est un peu joué le monsieur un
vraiment le père ce qui fut le chef
d'orchestre rien que ça de georges ulmer
entre autres de paul anka
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]